ich habe heute auch ein Thema
mitgebracht was mich bewegt und ich
freue mich die Meinungen hier von meinen
Mitdiskutanten zu hören denn in
Baden-Württemberg würde es
wahrscheinlich bald zwei g für Kinder
und Jugendliche geben bislang ist es ja
so dass Kinder und Jugendliche
ausgenommen sind also Kinder und
Jugendliche haben 3G wir müssen Tests
vorzeigen aber jetzt ist es bald so dass
für Kinder und Jugendliche unter 17
Jahren dann zwei g oder sogar zwei
geplus gelten könnte das könnte sich
nämlich bis zum 31 Januar noch nicht und
dann könnte es sich aber ändern ich habe
ein ganz ganz großes Problem damit dass
es 2G für Kinder und Jugendliche geben
könnte das geht ja dann auch schon ab 12
und zwar wollen dieses das Sozial- und
Kultusministerium haben sich darauf
geeinigt die Jugendlichen vom ersten
Februar im Freizeitbereich genauso zu
behandeln wie Erwachsene das geht für
mich nicht was Baden-Württemberg davor
hat und sie merken schon ich bin ja
eigentlich immer sehr konzentriert wenn
ich dieses Statement vorschlage aber
irgendwie weiß ich gar nicht wie ich
damit umgehen soll das also Kinder mit
12 Jahren dann ausgegrenzt werden sollen
in Baden-Württemberg auch im
Freizeitbereich ab Februar nächsten
Jahres wenn sie nicht geimpft sind und
ich höre jetzt auf zu reden und eröffnet
die Runde
ich schließe mich deine Meinung direkt
an wenn ich darf und steige ganz
harmonisch ein heute weil da kann ich
keine Grauzone also was Erwachsene
betrifft das ist die eine Sache wir
können für uns selbst entscheiden
momentan gibt es noch keinen Impfzwang
aber Kinder vom öffentlichen Leben
auszuschließen und ihr Leben dermaßen
einzuschränken solange wir noch nicht
hundertprozentig wissen was diese
Impfungen fünf oder zehn Jahren mit
unserem Körper macht da da werde ich
Fuchs Teufels wild wie man im
Schwabenland gesagt wenn ich komme aus
Baden-Württemberg ja ich finde schwierig
zu sagen dass es unethisch ist weil
eigentlich finde ich
ist nun mal zugelassen ab dieser
Altersgruppe 12 das heißt entweder sagt
man ist es für alle Leute unethisch zu
sagen ihr seid ausgeschlossen wenn ihr
euch nicht im verlasst also ich finde
das mit den Kindern ich sehe zwar auch
die anderen Kinder können die
Entscheidung nicht selber treffen das
heißt es kann ja auch sein dass ein
zwölfjähriges Kind sagt Mama ich will
geimpft werden dann sagen die Eltern
nein und dann wird das Kind
ausgeschlossen und das finde ich daran
so inakzeptabel also ja und es ist
tatsächlich so dass die sehr gut für
sich eigentlich schon entscheiden können
und wollen die kriegen halt Druck von
außen und dass dieser Druck das ist
etwas was wir generell glaube ich
diskutieren können aber ich finde für
die Kinder ist das würde ich jetzt ich
sehe es nicht als unethisch weil der
Impfstoff ist nun mal zugelassen ab dem
Alter und deswegen finde ich ist
grundsätzliche Frage Diskussion die wir
führen müssen für mich ist es ganz klar
eine kinderimpflicht durch die Hintertür
wenn ich ehrlich bin weil wenn Kinder
dann in Baden-Württemberg ab Februar
nächsten Jahres jetzt haben sie gerade
noch die Schonfrist dass sie bei 2G noch
nicht mitmachen müssen aber das finde
ich sehr sehr schwierig ich würde gerne
Anknüpfen an den Punkt den Sie gerade
ansprachen ob es generell unethisch ist
auch Erwachsene zu einer Impfung zu
drängen die einfach der Meinung sind sie
sind noch nicht bereit diesen Schritt zu
gehen und im Moment eigentlich man kann
ja nicht mal mehr einkaufen gehen ich
habe vor wenigen Tagen
Weihnachtseinkäufe machen wollen und
musste überall man wird überall getestet
an jeder Tür nicht nur einem Eingang der
Mall sondern tatsächlich in jedem
einzelnen laden muss man dann Ausweis
noch mal zeigen den im Status ja das
finde ich auch schon ist ziemlich
fortgeschritten in ziemlich kürzester
Zeit ist doch der nackte wahnsinn was
jetzt abgeht das ist einfach der nackte
nackte Wahnsinn was hier geht ich bin
geimpft bin der doppelkämpft alles muss
ich weil Deutschland glaube ich
irgendwie was hochrisikogebiet
eingestuft wenn ich in die Schweiz
zurück Fliege brauche ich noch einen
PCR-Test ich meine es ist unglaublich
auch noch einen Raumschiff Anzug
anziehen wo sind wir eigentlich gelandet
und wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt wo der
Staat mir ich bin vierfacher
Familienvater wo der Staat mir in die
Familien wenn ich jetzt in
Baden-Württemberg leben würde ich mir in
die Familie hinein regiert also das ist
für mich ich diese zweite vermutlich nie
mehr in Deutschland einreisen können und
auf Lebenslagen von jeder Kamera
verbannt werden das ist für mich ein
gesundheitstalibanismus der sich hier
fortpflanzt das ist also eine Art von
Grenzüberschreitung wo ich sagen muss
das geht zu weit das geht das geht
einfach nicht Hallo die Schweiz das
anders
wir können nicht nach Österreich wir
können nirgendwo mehr hin weil die
anderen Länder damit viel Regie wieder
Verfahren als ihr als als wir ja ich
will nicht sagen dass das richtig ist
aber sehr interessant selbst wenn wir
uns hier durchsetzen mit unserer Haltung
wir werden ja gar nicht weit kommen
sich dann immer wieder beruhigen ja es
gibt immer noch ein Land das irgendwie
nordkoreanischer unterwegs ist bezüglich
Corona als wir als Cent können wir
unsere schön zurücklehnen aber wenn ich
so in die Diskussionen einsteige auch
aus meinem freundesumfeld Familienumfeld
also da hört dann der Spaß auf also wenn
man sagen muss wenn man jetzt die Kinder
also ich habe Kinder und was mich
komplett beunruhigt ist der Grund warum
sie geimpft werden wollen denn ich habe
hohen Respekt vor jedem der sagt ich
habe Angst vor dieser Krankheit und lass
mich impfen ich selber bin dreifach
geimpft und ich nehme auch gerne noch
die vierte und die fünfte ich habe da
eine aber auch immer dazu sagen diese
Meinung vertreten
aber das gehört ja auch zum Bild dazu
also ich bin ich bin ja Zukunft
Skeptiker ich bin überhaupt kein
farmerskeptiker ich habe ich
auf Reisen gehe habe ich immer ein
pharmakoffer quasi dabei und ich hin und
ich weiß ja auch nicht was in der
Aspirin Tablette drin ist also ich bin
da auch ich habe auch ein Grundvertrauen
in die in die Wissenschaften auch
Grundvertrauen in die in die in die
Forschung aber wenn ich höre die
Begründung der meiner Kinder warum sie
geimpft werden sollen halte ich das für
unseriös meine Kinder meine Kinder sagen
nicht naja meine Kinder sind jetzt
zwischen 16 und 19 und die sagen sondern
denkenden Menschen und die sagen nicht
ich habe Angst vor der Krankheiten
möchte mich impfen lassen und ich sage
ich möchte eine Disco gehen oder ich
möchte ich ich möchte auf Reisen gehen
und deswegen lasse ich mich impfen das
halte ich für komplett unseriös und bei
dieser Druck der aufgebaut wird ich
finde ein eine eine eine Injektion in
deinem Körper in Kauf zu nehmen damit du
in die Disco gehen kannst das finde ich
so unseriös das kann
Pflege geimpft sind ich bin über 50 und
habe ich bin ich bin
ich habe Angst vor der ich habe Angst
vor der Krankheit aber meine
Kinder sind Pumpe gesund wie man wie man
in Bayern sagt und haben und ähm haben
eigentlich gar keinen Grund zu
besonderen Sorge werden immer von der
Gesellschaft tatsächlich aus dem aus dem
aus der Gesellschaft ausgeschlossen und
dürfen nichts mehr machen wenn sie sich
nicht impfen lassen ich finde das
unmöglich mir fehlen da die Worte und
was ist denn eigentlich die
wissenschaftliche Grundlage zahlt man
uns immer das ist alles Wissenschaft ist
alles Wissenschaft das ist glaube ich
sowieso nicht das ist alles Politik das
sind politische Entscheidungen man muss
sich heute schon rechtfertigen oder wenn
man sagt ich lass mich jetzt nicht auf
geheißte Staates impfen wirst du ja
schon fast als abergläubiger Voodoo
fertig bist einfach
beschwörungstheoretisch dann
rechtsextremer und das sind einfach ganz
schlimme Mechanismen die da abgehen die
da laufen und noch mal die Frage was ist
das die wissenschaftliche Grundlage
jetzt habe ich ein Jahr lang gehört die
Kinder sei nicht die Treiber Pandemie
sie ist wegen dieser omicronvariante hat
kein Corona bekommen obwohl sie in
unserer zwei welchen Quarantäne die vor
einer Woche beendet ist dass ich sollte
keine Bakterienschleuder mehr darstellen
heute
ist die komplette Quarantäne über war
sie in unserem Bett mein Mann und ich
hatten Corona sie hat es nicht bekommen
wir hatten keine Symptome und ging es
glücklicherweise sehr gut aber ein
tolles Beispiel das Kinder tatsächlich
offensichtlich nicht so anfällig zu sein
scheinen können zumindest kriegen sie
nicht so dolle Symptome
wir haben PCR-Test gemacht alle wenigen
Tage damit sie raus konnte und wir haben
wirklich aus dem gleichen Glas getrunken
die gleiche Gabel benutzt in den Tagen
also wir müssen nur sagen das ist ganz
toll dass es so bei dir lief es gibt
natürlich auch andere Beispiele
natürlich auch die neue Variante omnicom
da hört man jetzt wieder andere Sachen
zu ich bin keine Wissenschaftlerin was
ich aber gerade ganz schön finde ich an
dem Tisch ist Alexander hat beschrieben
warum er geimpft ist das war seine
freientscheidung der begründet hat Ich
habe mich auch freiwillig dazu
entschieden weil ich einfach mehr der
Wissenschaft traue als einem Virus den
ich nicht einschätzen kann der
wahrscheinlich im chinesischen Labor
gezüchtet wurde nur wahrscheinlich ich
sag nicht dass er es ist nicht dass ich
jetzt hier direkt wieder als Fake News
Frau abgestempelt werde aber ich finde
diese freie Entscheidung die ich auch
ganz bewusst getroffen habe mit der
Argumentation übrigens ich natürlich im
in Deutschland hergestellt mehr vertraue
als irgend so ein komischen Virus der
hinter dir sonst was mit mir macht das
war meine Entscheidung aber zum Beispiel
bei meiner Schwester die ist noch mal
sechs Jahre jünger haben wir auch
überlegt die hat sich dann auch impfen
lassen entscheiden selber frei
entschieden zwar heute Nachmittag auch
impfen lassen aber ich finde dieser
Druck der jetzt auf Kinder gemacht wird
allein schon die Überschrift des
Artikels die Schonfrist für Kinder und
Jugendliche ist vorbei wir beschreiben
das als Schonfrist das Kindergarten noch
kein 2G haben genau aber das habe ich
die Punkte was machen wir
gesellschaftlich mit dem Thema wir gehen
wir damit um was üben wir für den Druck
auf Leute aus und ich meine wir merken
ja was es gerade macht das macht eine
Spaltung der Gesellschaft es macht eine
Spaltung der Familien man fängt an mit
seinen Kindern über diese Themen zu
diskutieren das eigentlich fürchterlich
was das sozial für uns bedeutet und da
ist aber ein wichtiger Punkt anzusetzen
meine Frau ist immer wer spaltet denn
hier rein wir machen das eigentlich und
da muss man sagen es gibt ja nichts
Neues unter der Sonne das ist das
sympolitik ist ein politische
Anordnungen und das fürchterliche ist
doch einfach dass das das ganze als eine
Art
alternativloses Ebene absolut super
wissenschaftliches Programm ausgegeben
wird und immer mehr Leute das merke ich
die sind ja auch verzweifelt wie will
man da überhaupt noch dagegen sein wenn
du dagegen bist eben bist du schon halb
ein
rechtsextremer und und das ist wirklich
eine ungesunde Sache und ich hoffe jetzt
einfach dass in Deutschland also das
irgendwie diese neue Regierung jetzt
hier nicht da völlig noch über den